now an elevated metro line has collapsed
in mexico's capital sending a train
crashing down onto the cars below at
least 20 people
have been killed rescue crews have been
pulling people from the wreckage of the
carriages which are hanging
precariously over the roads around
70 injured people have been taken to
hospitals
around the city we can get more now from
manuel rapalo who's in
mexico city uh manor what happened
hello we've arrived we're about as close
as authorities are allowing us to get to
the scene
of the accident it's just past 2 a.m in
mexico city in the southwestern part
of town let me bring you in uh to what
this scene actually looks like i'm gonna
give you
more than just a sense this is the
actual scene that
uh that we're seeing here in mexico city
these are two metro cars
that have uh collapsed underneath the
structure that then collapse on top of
an overpass
pinning at least one car underneath and
what we know is uh what we've seen here
at uh at the scene of the accident and
what we've seen
from that surveillance footage that that
captured the moment where that
uh that elevated metro rail line
collapsed over those cars
sending a plume of dust and debris into
the sky now at the moment authorities
have sort of sectioned this area off
they're not allowing anybody to come
through that isn't a member of the army
national
guard or authorities or or first
responders
and they've actually taken a pause from
much of the
rescue work and the emergency work out
of fears that there could be further
structural damage that could be
potential for another collapse you can
see
the state of those two cars are just
hanging very precariously
over over the freeway the the police and
the authorities here
have sectioned off an entire secure
perimeter not allowing any of the
residents
to to come anywhere anywhere close to
the scene out of fear that there could
be
another collapse now the uh the mayor of
mexico city was here earlier
she confirmed that that that the the
death toll has now risen
to to 20 people with dozens others
injured what's unclear
is if everyone's been removed from from
these cars if authorities here and
rescue workers
have actually finished with the with the
rescue operations but we are continuing
to see
more members of the national guard
continue to arrive we're continuing to
see more members
of of emergency services continue to
arrive
uh and and more more than anything more
importantly than anything keeping people
away out of that fear
out of a potential second collapse a
very precarious situation
there manuel ropalo live from the scene
in mexico city thank you very much
indeed for bringing us the latest